[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka
guten Abend der Verlauf des Nato-Gipfels
gestern war für die Ukraine ja
enttäuschend und Präsident silensky
behielt sein Frust auch nicht bei sich
das sah zwischenzeitlich fast nach einem
Eklat aus zumindest nach sehr schlechter
Stimmung in Vilnius aber heute sieht die
Welt schon wieder etwas anders aus die
G7 als führende demokratische
Industrienationen haben der Ukraine
umfängliche und langfristige
militärische und wirtschaftliche
Unterstützung zugesagt und sind die G7
kein Militärbündnis und sie liefern
keine beistandsverpflichtungen aber
solche Zusagen von Ländern wie den USA
Frankreich Deutschland oder
Großbritannien sind auch nicht nichts
und sie sind eine Signal nach Moskau wir
hören nicht auf mit der Hilfe für die
Ukraine
wie spät ist es fragt ihr einen Raum in
Vilnius die Fahnen stehen schon wo wurde
mir selensky der ukrainische Präsident
auch Minuten vergehen die sich vor den
Kameras wie eine Ewigkeit anfühlen
müssen
selensky wartet auf dem deutschen
Kanzler in Vilnius und auf eine
Einladung der NATO beizutreten wird die
Öffentlichkeit heute Zeuge eines Streits
auf offener Bühne das fragen sich viele
am Morgen gestern hatte der ukrainische
Präsident noch gewettert wie absurd es
sei dass die NATO seinem Land keinen
Zeitplan zum Beitritt verspricht doch
statt des Kämpfers kommt da heute ein
Diplomat auf die Bühne
wir verstehen doch dass einige Angst
davor haben über unseren NATO-Beitritt
jetzt zu sprechen
niemand will einen Weltkrieg das ist
doch logisch und nachvollziehbar
wenig später Applaus für silensky im
Kreis der nato-spitzen es gibt die erste
Sitzung eines neuen NATO Ukraine Rates
neue waffenpakete und
Sicherheitsgarantien von den jesidenten
Staaten für die Zeit bis zu einem
möglichen NATO-Beitritt sie versprechen
auf Dauer Waffen Geld Geheimdienst
Informationen es geht um
Sicherheitspartnerschaft die dringend
notwendig ist und die es möglich macht
dass die Staaten die das Unterzeichnen
dann im konkreten Ihre Beiträge in der
aktuellen Situation weiter präzisieren
aber das auch ein Betten in eine
längerfristige Strategie auf die sich
die Ukraine dann auch verlassen kann
fragt sich nur wie sehr oder ob das Wort
Garantie wirklich trifft
im Nato-Generalsekretär zumindest ist
eine Unterscheidung wichtig
eine Sache ist Unterstützung zu
versprechen das ist wichtig aber das
unterscheidet sich sehr von der
Sicherheitsgarantie der NATO wenn du
angegriffen wirst verteidigt dich die
ganze Allianz in Vilnius wird silenski
heute vertröstet gibt sich aber
versöhnlich auch gegenüber dem Mann der
eine Einladung maßgeblich verhindert hat
US-Präsident Joe Biden der verspricht am
Abend in der litauischen Hauptstadt
wir werden nicht nachlassen unser
Engagement für die Ukraine wird nicht
schwächer
ein Versprechen vom Chef des wichtigsten
nato-staates garantiert wichtig aber
eben keine Garantie
[Musik]
beobachtet das für uns sind Vilnius
Florian wir haben es in deinem Beitrag
gesehen insgesamt heute alles
versöhnliche das war ja gestern noch
eine wirklich andere Atmosphäre oder
das kann man wohl sagen da gab es
heftige Diskussionen auch innerhalb der
NATO viele osteuropäische Staaten hatten
wieder und wieder auf eine Garantie eine
Einladung für die Ukraine gedrängt dass
man die eben bald zum Beitritt einlädt
und irgendwann haben dann nach meinen
Informationen doch ziemlich deutlich die
USA gesagt basta ist reicht es wird
diese Einladung jetzt nicht geben das
hat eben für viel Unverständnis und
Kritik auf der anderen Seite gesorgt und
das dann auch noch der ukrainische
Präsident selenski so unsanf dazwischen
Gerät da hat die Stimmung auch nicht
verbessert heute haben sich da viele mit
Kritik zurückgehalten bis auf einen der
britische Verteidigungsminister Ben
Wallace der ungewöhnlich deutlich sagte
er fordere von hier von der Regierung
von silenski mehr Zurückhaltung die
haben mir Dankbarkeit man müsse auch die
eigene Bevölkerung jeweils von den neuen
Waffenlieferungen überzeugen das ganze
zeigt meines Erachtens nach 500 Tagen
Krieg doch deutlicher
Ermüdungserscheinungen auf Seiten des
Westens aber man muss auch sagen noch
hält die NATO da eben durch
und jetzt bei dem Jahr auch und auch auf
diesem Gipfel nicht nur die Ukraine
sondern auch darum sich die natalender
selbst gegenüber Russland aufstellen und
verteidigen
in der Tat das Gerät beim Streit über
die Ukraine ist fast in Vergessenheit
aber auch das ist bemerkenswert diese
Neuaufstellung vielleicht zwei Beispiele
einerseits hat man hier neue
verteidigungspläne verabschiedet 4000
Seiten lange geheime Dokumente in denen
man festlegt wie man auf jeden einzelnen
Angriff jedes Szenario reagieren würde
natürlich geht es da vor allem auch um
mögliche Angriffe aus dem Osten aus
Russland und das zweite ist ein neues
Ziel bei den Verteidigungsausgaben da
wollen die NATO-Staaten künftig
dauerhaft mindestens zwei Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts für Militär
ausgeben für Verteidigung aktuell aber
verfehlen 20 der 31 NATO-Staaten dieses
Ziel darunter aktuell auch Deutschland
das heißt also hier werden viele Staaten
des Westens künftig deutlich mehr Geld
fürs Militär in die Hand nehmen müssen
und dann kommen wir jetzt nach
Deutschland zu innenpolitischen
Strategie Fragen die CDU hat einen neuen
Mann für die Abteilung Attacke das ist
ja ein wesentlicher Teil der job
Description eines Generalsekretärs
Schwächen der politischen Gegner
ausmachen Wirkungstreffer setzen aber
auch Inhalte formulieren manche
diedenkopf oder reiner Geißler waren
dabei so macht bewusst dass sie sogar in
Konkurrenz zum Parteichef gerieten die
Partei aber auch breit aufstellten auf
Carsten Linnemann den neuen bei der CDU
trifft das eher nicht zu insofern
verbindet sich mit dieser Personalie
auch eine strategische Entscheidung
berichtet Daniel putzen
formal geht Carsten Linnemann auf diesem
Posten eigentlich gar nicht er verstößt
gegen den regionalproports weil er wie
März aus NRW kommt er verstößt gegen die
Idee der Frauenquote zu der sich letztes
Jahr auch die CDU bekannte und dann ist
er auch noch Wirtschaftsfachmann genau
wie merkt egal sagt er das halbe
Saarland war mal im Bundeskabinett also
für mich spielt die Herkunft keine Rolle
sondern ausschließlich die Qualifikation
Klassenzimmer ist fest verankert in der
CDU er genießt in der Partei sehr hohes
Vertrauen wenn uns sofort hier im Haus
zusammensetzen mit dem Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern
denn die Zielmarke 2025 die
Bundestagswahl zu gewinnen funktioniert
nur wenn wir hier ein Team sind im Haus
und deswegen brauchen wir alle mit
Linnemann geht März nun gewisse Maßen
All-In nachdem die softvariante mit
sozialflügel und ostbezug nicht
funktioniert hat jetzt so lässt sich das
wohl deuten setzen März auf mehr märz
den er wirkt den vielen wie eine junge
Variante des Parteichefs er ist für
einen schärferen Kurs in der
Migrationspolitik hat sich nicht nur
hier von Angela Merkel distanziert und
sich lange bevor diese beiden hier
kürzlich an März Autorität rüttelten für
ihn als Kanzlerkandidaten ausgesprochen
die rein werden in der CDU ganz offenbar
geschlossen aus einem Bewusstsein heraus
wirtschaftspolitisch vielleicht auch
konservativ bürgerlicher angreifen zu
können die
Vorstöße von wüst und von Günther sind
ja eher liberale Vorstöße gewesen die
die merkelige Union als Sehnsuchtsort
beschreiben und da ist es eine
Abgrenzung Debatten anstoßen und
Gegenwind aushalten Kern des neuen
job-profils hat Lindemann schon zuvor
gemacht so forderte er etwa vor vier
Jahren eine vorschulpflicht für Kinder
die nicht ausreichend Deutsch sprechen
wir müssen jetzt loslegen wir müssen
jetzt an dem größten
integrationshemmende Sprache etwas tun
jüngst kriegt er an Überstunden und die
Arbeit von Rentnern steuerfrei zu
stellen gegen den Fachkräftemangel
und diese Debatten will ich führen am
Ende des Tages möchte ich meinen Beitrag
leisten das ist wieder eine CDU gibt wo
die Menschen genau wissen wofür die CDU
steht und wofür nicht
dafür brauche ich nicht zu anderen
Parteien schauen sondern dafür braucht
es CDU pur was das genau heißen soll
daran arbeitet er bereits und auch
künftig federführend am neuen
cdu-grundsatzprogramm breite
Rückendeckung gab es heute vom
Bundesvorstand der Linnemann einstimmig
bestätigte das ist vor allem eine
Vorbereitung auf das was ansteht eine
Europawahl im nächsten Jahr wichtige
Landtagswahlen die Bundestagswahl und da
macht es Sinn den inhaltlichen Prozess
den langfristigen das Grundsatzprogramm
und die Arbeit hier im Alltag
miteinander zu verzeihen ein bisschen
fühlte sich heute an nach zurück zum
Markenkern zurück in die Zukunft die
besagten Wahlen dürften entscheiden wie
diese Zukunft aussehen wird
und jetzt geht's
Bundesfinanzminister Lindner will die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit Deutschlands
stärken und dazu Unternehmen steuerliche
Entlastungen gewähren im Umfang von
rundjährlich rund 6 Milliarden Euro
verlautet der aus dem Finanzministerium
Lindner schlägt demnach fast 50
steuerpolitische Maßnahmen vor und
kernelement ist eine Prämie für
Investitionen in den Klimaschutz
der Verfassungsschutz in Brandenburg hat
die AFD Jugendorganisation junge
alternative Brandenburg als gesichert
rechtsextremistische Bestrebung
eingestuft die Positionen seien nicht
mit dem Grundgesetz vereinbar so in den
Minister stübken die brandenburgische
afd-chefin kündigte juristische Schritte
an
die Zahl der Menschen weltweit die
hungern ist in den vergangenen Jahren
wieder gestiegen nach einem UN-Bericht
waren 2022
735 Millionen Kinder und Erwachsene
betroffen über 100 Millionen mehr als
vor der corona-pandemie die als eine der
Gründe für den Anstieg gilt und 2,4
Milliarden Menschen hatten demnach im
vergangenen Jahr keinen dauerhaften
Zugang zu Nahrung
in Deutschland ist die Zahl der
Verkehrstoten im vergangenen Jahr
deutlich gestiegen sie lag aber weiter
unter dem Niveau der vor coronazeit nach
Angaben des Statistischen Bundesamtes
sind 2022 auf Deutschland Straßen
1788 Menschen bei Verkehrsunfällen ums
Leben gekommen das sind 226 mehr als im
Jahr 2021 ein Anstieg also um
9%. auffällig sei vor allem der Anstieg
von Unfällen unter Alkoholeinfluss
Mieter die Auskünfte vom Vermieter
wollen um gegen einen Verstoß gegen die
mietpreisbremse vorzugehen haben dafür
mehr Zeit das hat der Bundesgerichtshof
entschieden demnach beginnt die
dreijährige Verjährungsfrist nicht mit
dem mietvertragsschluss sondern erst
nachdem der Mieter Auskunft verlangt hat
anhand von Informationen zum Baujahr zu
Modernisierungen und zur Höhe der
vormiete können Mieter überprüfen ob die
ortsübliche Vergleichsmiete mehr als 10%
überschritten werden darf
kaum ein Gesetz hatte in letzter Zeit
für so erbitterte Kämpfe gesorgt wie das
sogenannte
renaturierungsgesetz übersetzt als
Gesetz zur Wiederherstellung der Natur
nicht dass das Europäische Parlament
sonst nur ein Bällebad wäre aber so hat
gerungen wird dort nicht so häufig die
Abstimmung heute morgen in Straßburg war
eine regelrechte entscheidungsschlag bei
der jede Stimme zählte und aus dem Feld
der Gegner einige Abgeordnete ausfährten
Fraktionsdisziplin ist im
Europaparlament weitaus schwieriger
herzustellen als der nationalen
Parlamenten am Ende ging das Gesetz
knapp durch was ist damit auf sich hat
und warum darüber so heftig gestritten
wurde erläutert Isabel Schäfers
das Naturschutzgebiet dode-bemde liegt
südlich von der belgischen Stadt Löwen
vor gut 20 Jahren wurde hier begonnen
der Natur wieder freien Lauf zu lassen
don't touch the river anymore wir haben
gesagt wir berühren den Fluss einfach
nicht mehr wir lassen das Flussbett sich
entwickeln lassen Bäume wachsen und ins
Wasser fallen so dass alles im Flussbett
ganz natürlich fließt das Gebiet soll
neben dem Atem auch dem Hochwasserschutz
dienen und bestand bereits den
Realitätscheck die Flutkatastrophe die
vor zwei Jahren das Aartal zerstörte
traf auch Belgien
Überschwemmung aber für die Stadt Löwen
war das absolut kein Problem Löwen würde
überhaupt nicht überflutet das ist
darauf zurückzuführen dass das System
hier perfekt funktioniert
um solche Gebiete für ganz Europa ging
es heute im Europaparlament die
Abstimmung ungewöhnlich emotional sie
endete mit Jubel und Erleichterung auf
der einen Seite und Enttäuschung auf der
anderen knapp stimmten die Abgeordneten
für das Gesetz zur Wiederherstellung der
Natur
eine große Mehrheit des Europäischen
Parlamentes hat heute gezeigt dass sie
für Artenschutz einstehen will und dass
sie was gegen das Artensterben tun will
gegen die Blockade der konservativen und
das ist ein richtig gutes Zeichen ziel
des Gesetzes ist unter anderem 20
Prozent der europäischen Land und
Meeresfläche bis 2030 wieder
herzustellen mehr Flüsse sollen wieder
natürlich fließen Wälder sollen
aufgeforstet werden die konservative
Europäische Volkspartei EVP hatte bis
zuletzt gegen das Gesetz gekämpft
zusammen mit Europas Bauern sie
befürchten Eingriffe in ihre
Produktionsweise und Verluste von
Agrarflächen Größe setzt auf Verbote
Herausnahme der Fläche was am Ende auch
die Ernährungssicherung gefährden würde
die städtischen Politiker die nicht auf
dem Land Leben bestimmen wie ich
produzieren soll und meinen immer noch
mehr Kontrollen uns auf die Betriebe zu
hetzen die Bauern stehen im Rücken an
der Wand und die haben diese Sachen satt
im Europaparlament ging es längst nicht
mehr um eine inhaltliche
Auseinandersetzung sondern um einen
grundsätzlichen politischen Kampf die
EVP hatte bereits im Vorfeld die
eigentlich üblichen Verhandlungen
zwischen den Fraktionen verlassen und so
einen Kompromiss verhindert
diese populistische Angstmacherei statt
der Benennung der wirklichen Probleme
das ist sind die Gefahren für unsere
langfristige Ernährungssicherheit herr
Weber hören sie auf Wahlkampf auf Kosten
der Natur auf Kosten der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auf Kosten unserer
Lebensgrundlagen zu machen Manfred Weber
wurde zu einer zentralen Figur in dieser
Auseinandersetzung ein Vorwurf die
Europäische Volkspartei unter seiner
Führung nehme bewusst in Kauf mit
Rechtspopulisten zu stimmen wenn die
Linken keine Argumente mehr haben dann
ist die letzte Lösung immer den anderen
vorzuwerfen Populisten oder Trump Pisten
zu sein diese Attacken müssen aufhören
dass das Gesetz so kurz vorm scheitern
stand zeigt wie sich die Fronten im
Europa-Parlament verhärten eine
Entwicklung die wohl weitergeht doch das
Gesetz zur Renaturierung hat es heute
geschafft jetzt muss es weiter zwischen
Parlament und Mitgliedstaaten verhandelt
werden
nachher im heute journal Update gibt es
dazu noch ein Interview mit Peter Liese
dem umweltpolitischen Sprecher der EVP
das mit dem Klimawandel die Häufigkeit
sogenannter Extremwetter Ereignisse
zunimmt davor warnen Klimaforscher und
Meteorologen schon lange was das
bedeutet Extremwetter bekommen wir ja
auch jetzt zu Lande immer wieder zu
spüren Hitze Dürre einerseits
Überflutungen andererseits
diese extreme sind derzeit auch in
Nordamerika zu beobachten in einer
gewaltigen Dimension und mit
katastrophalen Folgen darüber berichtet
Benjamin Daniel
wieder mal eine sogenannte wärmekuppel
über dem Süden der USA extreme Hitze
täglich neue Rekorde und zwei Probleme
die nicht neu sind aber immer größer
werden
zum einen steigen die Temperaturen immer
weiter durch die globale Erwärmung die
wir Menschen mit unseren fossilen
Brennstoffen herbeiführen hinzu kommt
das vor kurzem die el nino-phase
begonnen hat also jenes Zeitinterval in
dem der pazifische Ozean weniger Hitze
aufnehmen kann und mehr in der
Atmosphäre bleiben bleibt
mehr als 50 Millionen Menschen sind in
den kommenden Tagen der gefährlichen
Hitzewelle ausgesetzt ein extrem jagt
das nächste in Oklahoma stehen ganze
Landstriche unter Wasser ähnliche Bilder
in Roermond zwar sinkt der Pegel am
reizwil da mittlerweile wieder dennoch
ist die Gefahr dass er den Wassermassen
nachgeben könnte noch nicht gebannt der
US-Präsident hat für den Bundesstaat aus
der Ferne den Katastrophenfall
ausgerufen
zwei Rettungsteams sind aus Nord
Carolina zu Hilfe gekommen ein weiteres
aus message schusets ist unterwegs in so
einem Fall müssen einfach alle mit
anpacken
nächste Katastrophe seit Wochen schon
zieht der Rauch der kanadischen
Waldbrände um die Welt vielerorts an der
US-Ostküste gibt es aufgrund der
verpesteten luftregelmäßig die
Empfehlung nicht nach draußen zu gehen
wenn es nicht absolut nötig ist
das alles sind Symptome des Klimawandels
mehr Hitze und mehr Dürer lassen Brände
schneller entstehen und länger andauern
und die Auswirkungen spüren die Menschen
im Moment besonders denn mit Hitze oder
Luftverschmutzung kommt man noch ganz
gut klar aber beides kombiniert ist sehr
schlimm
und es wird noch schlimmer werden warnen
Experten
der Klimawandel könnte auch die
Ausbreitung von Infektionskrankheiten
und neuartigen Viren begünstigen was das
bedeuten kann war in der corona-pandemie
zu sehen und dabei sind die
Langzeitfolgen noch gar nicht
ausreichend erforscht das kombit nicht
einfach nur eine Atemwegserkrankung ist
sondern Gefäße und Gewebe angreifen kann
wurde ja relativ früh festgestellt wie
nachhaltig eine Infektion die Gesundheit
beeinträchtigen kann und wie viele
Betroffene es gibt das wurde erst nach
und nach sichtbar mehr Forschung wäre
hier dringend erforderlich doch die
Mittel des Bundesgesundheitsministers
sind begrenzt
die immun defektambulanz der Berliner
Charité Professor Scheiben Bogen ist die
Expertin auf dem Gebiet der Behandlung
von postcode Mia dico erkrankte im März
2020 an Corona über drei Jahre später
ist nur eine videosprechstunde möglich
weil sie zu schwach ist um persönlich
vorbeizukommen
[Musik]
kognitive Arbeit so am Rechner
und an guten Tag schaffe ich dann auch
noch sowas wie Körperpflege und essen
das sind die guten Tage es gibt sehr
viele sehr schlechte Tage
das ist wirklich ein Irrer Zustand also
sich nicht bewegen können und
gleichzeitig Rast dein Herz als wärst du
joggen
daran kann man sich nicht gewöhnen ne
das ist einfach nach wie vor sehr schwer
wir können ungefähr 25 bis 30 Patienten
in der Woche bei uns sehen das reicht
leider für die regionalversorgung bei
weitem nicht aus wir haben momentan
Wartezeiten von etwa einem halben Jahr
für eine Sprechstunde bei uns das ist
eine Katastrophe geschätzt leiden 2
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland an zum
Teil schwerwiegenden Langzeitfolgen Karl
Lauterbach hatte für Forschung und
Behandlung 100 Millionen Euro
angekündigt jetzt sind es nur 40
Millionen laut Lauterbach ist dieses
wenige jetzt aber plötzlich sehr viel
wenn es uns gelingt die 40 Millionen die
jetzt für versorgungsforschungen
aufgebaut werden wenn es uns gelingt
diese wirklich gut einzusetzen dass wir
gute Projekte haben dann sind wir gut
bedienen und auch gut unterwegs im
Moment sei die Situation desaströs sagt
Professor Schiefer er behandelt vor
allem Menschen die nach kobit Impfungen
schwer krank geworden sind auch diesen
Patienten müssen wir ganz offen
gegenübertreten und da appelliere ich an
meine Kollegen nicht die Augen zu
verschließen zu sagen es gibt die
Erkrankung nicht ich möchte sie nicht
behandeln bilden wir uns gemeinsam
weiter und sorgen wir dafür dass diese
vielen 10.000 Patienten die wir durch
Corona in unsere Hände bekommen haben
dass die adäquat versorgt werden es
brauche eine nachhaltige Finanzierung um
postkowith und Postbank Patienten zu
helfen
geben Sie uns das Geld geben sie uns
jedes Jahr an der Charité zum Beispiel
fünf Millionen und Herren Schiefer seine
5 Millionen und fünf sechs anderen auch
dann bin ich mir relativ sicher dann
haben wir in drei Jahren die Medikamente
die wir brauchen das klingt nach einem
Stück Hoffnung für viele Patientinnen
und Patienten die bislang häufig mit
ihrem Leid allein gelassen wurden 100
Millionen Euro waren versprochen jetzt
ist es noch nicht einmal die Hälfte auch
das sagt etwas aus
und jetzt noch mal Heinz mit Nachrichten
aus der Wirtschaft die Inflation in den
USA geht weiter zurück für den Juni
meldet das Arbeitsministerium einen
Anstieg der Verbraucherpreise von 3% im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr Frank Bittmann
sind die USA also bei der Inflation über
den Berg ja darüber ist man sich noch
nicht wirklich einig es war heute beides
zu hören die die sagten dieser Rückgang
in die Nähe der angestrebten zwei
Prozent sei der ersehnte
Befreiungsschlag aber auch die die
warnen die Inflation sei hartnäckig der
Preisdruck immer noch hoch fakt ist die
Teuerung in den USA spricht sich weiter
merklich ab die aktuelle Rate von
3,0%, ist die niedrigste seit etwas mehr
als zwei Jahren diese Entwicklung führt
jetzt die Hoffnung dass die wichtigen
Notenbanken so langsam den Fuß vom Gas
nehmen und den zahlreichen
Leitzinserhöhungen nun kleinen keine
weiteren oder nur noch wenige folgen
lassen ausgemachte Sache ist das
allerdings keines
und wie sieht es für den Euroraum für
Deutschland aus ist auch nur eine Frage
der Zeit bis sich die Inflation auch so
abschwächt naja wir werden da auch noch
hinkommen ganz sicher aber wir haben
noch hier zu Lande einen weiteren Weg
und nicht die US-amerikanischen
Verhältnisse die Teuerung in der
Eurozone lag zuletzt noch bei 5,5% und
in Deutschland sogar über 6%
folgerichtig werden weitere
Zinsanhebungen durch die EZB erwartet
auch in den USA denken Sie über weitere
Zinsschritte nach aber seit heute
vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so laut die
Stimmung an den Aktienmärkten am Abend
jedenfalls gut der rückläufige trennt
bei der Inflation sorgt für starken
Kurse der DAX konnte sich heute weiter
rund anderthalb Prozent nach oben
Punkten
vielen Dank gerne
die frühere Ministerpräsidentin von
Schleswig-Holstein Heide simone ist ist
gestorben im Alter von 80 Jahren sie war
Deutschlands erste Landeschefin und
regierte das nördlichste Bundesland bis
2005 vor einigen Jahren machte die
SPD-Politikerin ihre Parkinson
Erkrankung öffentlich und zog sich immer
mehr zurück ein Nachruf von Tim Krüger
eine vollblutpolitikerin war sie die das
Rampenlicht suchte die Popularität
genoss und eine steile Karriere machte
2005 aber das hier Ende nach der
Landtagswahlen Schleswig-Holstein
verweigert ihr ein Unbekannter
Abgeordneter aus den eigenen Reihen die
Gefolgschaft bei der Wahl zum
Ministerpräsidentin Heide Simones den
Tränen nach nach zwölf Jahren als
Ministerpräsidentin Abschied von
Parteien und Politik
ich war immer gerne mit dabei
leidenschaftlich mit dabei und ich finde
es hat sich gelohnt
1969 tritt sie in die SPD ein im
Bundestag macht sie schnell als
finanzpolitisches Nachwuchstalent auf
sich aufmerksam und der
Ministerpräsident björn Engholm wird sie
Finanzministerin in Schleswig-Holstein
1993 beerbte ihn als er im Sog der
Barsche Affäre zurücktreten muss Heide
Simones wird die erste
Ministerpräsidentin der Bundesrepublik
wieder einmal hat sie sich in der
Männerwelt durchgesetzt ich habe
wirklich in der männerdominierten Welt
angefangen und habe auch immer nur
Bereiche gemacht die von Männern
nominiert war und der Hinweis ich bin
doch so kleines zartes Mädchen und komme
aus dem hohen Norden hätte die zum
Lachen vor Freude also das war's dann
lernt man das relativ schnell und dann
arbeitet man an bestimmten Stellen wo es
drauf ankommt genauso wie diese
männerregelung einen herum auch nach
ihrer politischen Karriere ging es
turbulent weiter als Vorsitzende von
UNICEF Deutschland trat sie im Zuge der
Affäre um Provisionszahlungen ein
Spenden einen Werber zurück
und Heide Simones hat die Bundesrepublik
eine der leidenschaftlichsten
beliebtesten aber auch streitbarsten
Politiker Persönlichkeiten überhaupt
verloren
der tschechisch französische
Schriftsteller Milan kunderer wurde mit
seinem Roman die unerträgliche
Leichtigkeit des Seins Welt berühmt
jetzt ist kunderer im Alter von 94
Jahren gestorben
günthera lebte seit 1975 in Paris seine
Bücher wurden in viele Sprachen
übersetzt und millionenfach verkauft er
hielt zahlreiche internationale
Auszeichnungen darunter die
Literaturpreis der Akademie francais
es gibt aktuelle Unwetterwarnungen des
Deutschen Wetterdienstes gewarnt wird
vor schweren Gewittern mit heftigem
Starkregen und Hagel in Teilen von
Baden-Württemberg und von Bayern
und jetzt noch die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr zwei sieben neun neun zehn 21 30
Superzahl 2 und weitere Gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto.df.de und im
zdf-557
so viel von uns gleich nach dem Wetter
geht es mit dem auslandjournal weiter
unter anderem mit einer Reportage aus
Italien das unter Extremwetter leidet
und um 0:30 Uhr gibt's
[Musik]
guten Abend so schön der Blick in den
Himmel sein kann vor den Gewittern wie
hier gestern in Engelstadt so wenig
erfreulich sind dann die Auswirkungen am
Boden so heftige Unwetter werden die
jetzt nicht mehr erwarten denn das
hochfee schiebt sich zu uns rein aber
über dem Atlantik wird morgen abend
schon das Tief schandor sich warm laufen
für Gewitter am Samstag es bleibt also
bei diesem Auf und Ab mal ist es schwül
heißt dann wieder etwas weniger warm nur
kühl wird es eigentlich nie es sei denn
nachts heute Nacht werden sie gut
durchlüften können bei meist 15 bis 10
Grad nur in Sachsen Bayern unterm
oberrheinland ist etwas milder heute
Nacht gibt's noch Schauer und Gewitter
zum Teil auch längeren Regen hier in
Süddeutschland auch im Nordwesten sind
einige Schauer und Gewitter unterwegs
sonst bleibt es trocken und das macht
sich auch bei der Waldbrandgefahr morgen
bemerkbar die bleibt nämlich hier im
Nordosten zum Teil sehr hoch im
Nordwesten und im Süden dagegen gibt's
eine kleine Verschnaufpause da gibt's
nämlich auch morgen noch Regenfälle auch
einzelne Gewitter des Nordwesten
regenschau und Gewitter im Südosten
ziehen ab dazwischen ist es freundlich
bei Westwind und so liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen bei angenehmen
19 bis 28 Grad und dann wird es erstmal
schwül heiß zum Samstag aber schon am
Sonntag liegen die Temperaturen wieder
bei etwas angenehmeren 21 bis 30 Grad
und sie haben also schon wann die
Unwetter kommen am Samstag und zwar von
Westen guten Abend